After more than a decade in development,
Disney’s newest action-adventure epic
called “Jungle Cruise'' has finally
charted a course into theaters.
Before you see it, here’s
everything we know so far.
Back in 2018, it looked like we'd be seeing
"Jungle Cruise" much sooner. As the film
pushed through its development schedule,
the Walt Disney Company was prepared to
roll the film out as early as 2019, and
set an initial release date for October
of that year. That would have pitted the film
against eventual hits like "Joker." However,
well before that release date was
upon us, Disney shifted the film.
There was some speculation at the time
that "Jungle Cruise" had been moved to
occupy a prime theatrical release window that had
previously been reserved for a "Star Wars" film.
Remember, in 2018 Disney was still purportedly
working toward a goal of releasing a "Star
Wars" flick every year, alternating between
main saga stories and spinoffs. Then "Solo:
A Star Wars Story" arrived to disappointing
box office returns in May of 2018,
setting the stage for a bit of a retooling. By
2019, there were no "Star Wars" films planned
for 2020, so "Jungle Cruise" was tapped in to
compete in the busy summer box office schedule.
We got another potential release date after
that first false start: July 24, 2020. It was
going to be a classic sweet summer blockbuster,
just the way things used to be. Unfortunately,
thanks to the pandemic, that 2020 date has come
and gone. A few rumors circulated that Disney
might go the VOD route with the first entry in
its franchise, but that all proved to be hearsay.
Disney remained committed to a traditional
theatrical release for its adventurous tentpole.
Fear not, Disney fans, "Jungle Cruise" will enjoy
a traditional theatrical release on July 30,
2021, and it seems like this
one's really going to take.
That means this release date comes almost
three full years after the formal conclusion
of filming back in September 2018. We'll
have to wait for the press junkets to see
if Johnson and Blunt even remember what
the movie's about. Mark your calendars.
After years of development, the first official
trailer finally arrived online in October of 2019.
The footage revealed an action-adventure
comedy that owes a lot to previous
period pieces in the subgenre.
Think of Disney's own "Pirates
of the Caribbean" and Universal's
"Mummy" franchise from the 2000s.
"We are in serious trouble."
The trailer begins by establishing the film
as a period drama set sometime in the early
20th century, though not so early that
automobiles aren't prevalent. From there,
it's more-or-less non-stop action and comedy. We
get to meet our main characters, Lily and Frank,
and we see the two of them meet and team
up. But what we don't see a whole lot of
is the actual jungle cruise the characters
are set to embark on. Still, there's just
enough here to hint that the trip will soon turn
supernatural with help from an ancient curse.
A second full-length trailer that
came down the pike in 2021 is even
more absolutely action-packed. It
keeps the focus on Blunt and Johnson,
often in pursuit of or being
pursued by some nasty business,
supernatural or otherwise. It also provides a few
more glimpses of the actual cruise in question.
There's even some Jesse Plemons action
in what looks to be a German U-Boat.
“Hallöchen!”
This is likely the final glimpse of the project
before game time, so go ahead and fire it up.
"Jungle Cruise" is set to be a rollicking
action-comedy vehicle in the vein of past
Disney hits like "Pirates of the Caribbean." As
with Johnny Depp and the first "Pirates" film,
one of the keys to the project's success
is picking a star to frame the film around,
and then filling out a compelling ensemble.
In the case of "Jungle Cruise," the
star role will be filled by not one but
two stars with experience in both action and
comedy. The film's leading man is Dwayne Johnson,
who began circling the movie as far back as
2015, and finally hopped aboard in 2017. In 2018,
it was revealed that Johnson's co-star
for the film would be Emily Blunt,
who's proven her action chops on films like
"Edge of Tomorrow" and "A Quiet Place."
She’s also already had major successes with Disney
in films like "Into the Woods" and "Mary Poppins
Returns." Both leads are known commodities, and
by the looks of the trailers released to date,
a lot of the movie's success will
be hanging on their performances.
While Johnson and Blunt are the key leads to the
film, they're not the only stars attached. The
film will also feature "Breaking Bad" and "Fargo"
standout Jesse Plemons in a villainous role.
In addition, British comedian Jack Whitehall stars
as the brother of Blunt's character. Édgar Ramírez
plays a mercenary leading another expedition to
the Tree of Life in direct competition with the
Johnson-Blunt cruise. "Billions" star Paul
Giamatti is involved in a role originally
described as a "crusty harbormaster." So then,
it's as star-studded as you might expect from
the franchise Disney hopes will become the
successor to "Pirates of the Caribbean."
"Jungle Cruise" is a period film that's
heavy on the kind of action-comedy blend
that inspired classics like
the "Indiana Jones" films.
It's a swashbuckling adventure that will feature
no small number of set pieces and big effects.
The film follows Lily, a scientist who makes
a shocking discovery in London that could lead
her to the legendary Tree of Life. The trouble
is, the Tree lies deep in the Amazon rainforest,
which means she's got to travel to South
America and set herself up with transportation.
Once there, she meets Frank, a jungle cruise
captain who seems more interested in conning
tourists out of their money than helping anyone to
find a place that sounds like it's make-believe.
Lily and her brother have plenty of money
to hire Frank, though, so he takes the job.
From there, it's an all-out adventure
into the heart of the Amazon river,
but the journey to the Tree of Life won't be
easy. Lily's not the only one trying to find it,
of course, and it turns out she and Frank
may also be contending with an ancient curse.
All the elements are there. The quest. The
elevated, fantasy-historical setting. The stylish
visual effects. Heck — there's even an ancient
curse. It really is "Curse of the Black Pearl" on
the Amazon River in the best possible ways. There
are certainly worse films to emulate, after all.
The film's journey to the big
screen begins with the theme park
attraction's opening at Disneyland
in 1955. For our purposes, though,
the real road to a movie version of the ride
kicked off in the 2000s, after Walt Disney
Pictures saw major success with "Pirates of
the Caribbean: The Curse of the Black Pearl."
That film, also based on a Disney Parks
attraction, launched an action-adventure
franchise for the studio, so Disney started to
mine other possible park rides for film material.
"Jungle Cruise" seemed like a natural fit, and in
2006 Disney began trying to nail down a script.
"Jungle Cruise" took what seemed at the time
like a big leap toward the screen back in 2011.
At this time, it was reported by EW that Tom
Hanks and Tim Allen, the duo that helped make
"Toy Story" a hit, would team up again to star
in the film. That pairing ultimately fizzled,
and by 2015 Dwayne Johnson was expressing
interest in the project. Johnson was dubbed
the film's official star in 2017, and by
2018 "Jungle Cruise" had begun shooting.
“Here we go.”
In 2017, with Johnson officially onboard to
star in the film, "Jungle Cruise'' began to
set up the rest of its creative team — both
in front of and behind the camera. Johnson,
as he has in many of his recent blockbusters,
took a rather active role in the process,
because he's also serving as one of the project's
producers. In the spring of 2017 the film began
searching for a director, and Johnson expressed
a preference for "Wonder Woman" helmer Patty
Jenkins. Jenkins ultimately stayed at Warner
Bros. to direct a "Wonder Woman" sequel,
and by the summer of 2017 Jaume Collet-Serra was
revealed as the director after passing on the
opportunity to direct a "Suicide Squad" sequel.
That "Suicide Squad" film eventually went to
James Gunn of "Guardians of the Galaxy" fame, so
everyone pretty much ended up where they belonged.
Though "Jungle Cruise" is being positioned by
Disney as a crowd-pleasing action adventure flick,
the film began generating controversy well
before its release. In August of 2018,
Jack Whitehall announced via Instagram that he'd
been cast in the film. It was later revealed
that he'd be playing the brother of Emily Blunt's
character. That same month, a report surfaced from
U.K. tabloid The Sun which revealed Whitehall's
character would be among the first major openly
gay characters in a Disney production.
Describing his character, the report said,
“[His character is] one who is hugely
effete, very camp and very funny."
The report quickly generated controversy,
not because Disney would feature an openly
gay character in the film, but because of how
the character would reportedly be portrayed.
Many social media users worried that Disney was
simply leaning back on tired gay stereotypes
for its first major gay character. Others were
concerned about who would play the role. That
Whitehall, a straight man, would be playing such
a potentially groundbreaking role for Disney,
instead of a gay actor, was
also a point of contention.
Disney has not officially responded to the
controversy, but Whitehall has also gained
defenders since the outrage. We'll just have to
wait until July 30 to see how it all pans out.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.